i don't know about you but when i sit
down i want to relax i want to indulge a
little bit
i open up a pint of ice cream i don't
want my ice cream
to call me a white supremacist that's i
don't ask a lot of my ice cream i ask
for it to be
cold a little bit soft sweet maybe have
some little chocolate chips in it and
not call me a white supremacist
but that would be too much to ask from
ben
jerry's so ben and jerry's yesterday
famously a liberal brand or a leftist
brand they tweet out quote
the murder of dante wright is he's the
guy who was
shot by the woman cop while he was
under arrest for a weapons charge and
then he fled
the the murder of dante wright is rooted
in white supremacy
and results from the intentional
criminalization
of black and brown communities this
system can't be reformed it must be
dismantled and a real system of public
safety built from the ground rebuilt
from the ground up
none of that is true but more to the
point and i
i cannot stress this enough
this is coming from ice cream nothing
they said is true it's
no evidence that he was murdered and no
evidence it was rooted in white
supremacy
no evidence that we ought to dismantle
the entire legal system in this country
moreover it's not even those two hippies
who's founded the company
ben jerry's is owned by a multinational
corporation called unilever
with annual revenue upwards of 60
billion dollars
why do we tolerate this why do we
tolerate a multinational corporation
coming into our country trying to
undermine our entire legal order
they are saying right here you need to
upend the entire american legal order
why do we tolerate that
we should we should punish them for that
it is not conservative
to allow giant multinational
corporations with 60 billion dollars in
revenue to undermine our whole
constitutional republic
nothing conservative at all but michael
the free market yeah okay
great great how long is that market
going to remain free with radicals like
this
using american freedom to undermine
american freedom probably not very long
hey hey hey before you go i need you to
smash
that subscribe button hit it ring the
bell
you know sometimes youtube doesn't
always want to recommend these videos
and people's feeds
so make sure you do that and you will
not miss another video
[Music]
you